because it's The Final Countdown no
actually we're like dead in the middle
of the controls we're not even close but
hey everybody it's Mike frieder with
on-call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week and if you're binge watching me you
got a lot more binging to do baby let's
get ready to purge all right this week
we're talking about cmfc control
ia.l2-3.5.10 store and transmit only
cryptographically protected passwords
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 800 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I have great news for you
you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
a cmfc control ia.l 2-3.5.10 store and
transmit only cryptographically
protected passwords now on the surface
you might think to yourself well of
course passwords would be encrypted but
here's the thing windows isn't the only
place UI is stored many companies create
their own systems and processes in order
to serve their own unique needs in some
cases this requires them to create
custom programs which often do not
follow security best practices there's a
hint all right if you have an in-house
design program it's probably not all
that secure and you should probably have
somebody actually do a Security review
of it in any event no matter how you are
working with passwords you must make
sure they are stored and transmitted in
an encrypted way even if you've I had
the software developed yourself guys I'm
just going to tell you I've had a ton of
applications over a 20 plus year career
developed and I'm just going to tell you
that unless you specifically ask your
programmer to encrypt the passwords
they're going to put the that password
field it's gonna be a clear text field
and SQL all right nine times out of ten
I'm not even kidding it's just gonna be
sitting there for anybody to be able to
scan uh you know or packet sniff all
right let's look more into what the
assessors are looking for on this one
two big controls all right determinive
passwords are cryptographically
protected in storage uh again here's an
example I'll just kind of pull out the
easy button here active directory stores
passwords required for system access
active director utilizes Des for
backwards compatibility and then with
CNG bcrypt AES 256-bit encryption which
is fips 140-2 compliant that's the
official answer I would probably give
all right determinative passwords are
cryptographically protected in transit
uh again talk about the Windows system
right the NT hash is protected by two
layers of encryption in transit and then
of course the final third assessment
point we would say hey look passwords
are actually never really sent in
transit there's a tokenized system and
again we just want to make sure that
passwords are not sent remotely there so
and on call we work with defense
contractors just like you to come up
with awesome answers like that okay if
you've had this defars nist itar and
cmfc compliance stuff dropped into your
lap like a seagull on a sunny day the
good news is we teach you how to level
up and be a proper on-call compliance
hero for your company we help you
eliminate gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliances your secret weapon
to land more Defense work with higher
profit margins now that's what becoming
an on-call compliance hero can do for
you if you're looking for more help
getting compliant our compliance experts
are always on call for you visit cmmc
compliance secrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to subscribe button to hit the
Subscribe but sorry I have to say it
three times because I can tell you
haven't subscribed yet so I'm just just
hit the Subscribe button just do it it
makes me it makes us happy like it
actually like literally I don't know if
you know this or not quick quick window
into our marketing department here at
oncall when there is a subscribe button
that gets pressed there's actually a
Gong in the corner and we all hit the
gong it's actually a race to the gong
it's kind of a funny thing okay we do it
it's like that's our win because in
marketing we don't do sales we just we
hit the gong because we got new
subscribers or we hit a New Prospect or
you know whatever you know how it goes
anyway until next compliance tip my
friends stay safe and secure out there
make us hit the gong by subscribing and
I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
all right